Speaker 1: All right, today we're going to be
speaking with Mike Lyndell, Mike Lyndell will be
a familiar face and name to many in our audience,
CEO and inventor of my pillow. Mike, I really
appreciate the opportunity to chat with you today.
Speaker 4: Thanks for having me on.
Speaker 1: Of course, so listen, you first came
to my attention, I first became aware of you
at the start of the pandemic. Donald Trump held
this event at the White House and announced,
here are some business people that are going to
be doing things to help us. You were going to be,
if I recall correctly, making masks and maybe even
some other things. How did you first come to to
meet Donald Trump and that relationship start?
Speaker 4: Well, it was the summer of twenty
sixteen, he invited me to Trump Tower, I was
August 15, 2016. It was a private meeting.
I went in there, it was about thirty five minutes,
just him and I and I walked out of there and
I didn't you know, I didn't I come from a past
of addiction and stuff. I didn't think politics
affected me, but I did walk out of his office,
said he's going to be the greatest president
ever if he's if he's with all the
things we talked about. We talked about,
you know, my pillow being made in the USA.
We talked about I said I was going to have a
platform, which I do the Lyndell Recovery
Network dog, which helps addicts. And he said,
I'm going to stop the drugs pouring in. And we
we just had this back and forth. And I went to my
went to his employees afterwards and I asked
them, I kind of did my due diligence. I'm going
it's just real. I mean, the only agenda he had
was to help our country and and help people.
And that's what I and they all said, yes, he's
amazing boss, amazing man. And they all had a
personal story about him. And then when I got
back to Minnesota and I did a press release and
you didn't think I shot someone, they attacked me
and called me a racist and called me everything.
And all I did was say I had a meeting with with
Donald Trump. Yeah, it was running for president.
Speaker 1: You are at that event at the White
House that I mentioned at the start of the
pandemic. You you said that Donald Trump
was, quote, chosen by God. How how did God
reveal to you that that he had chosen Trump?
Speaker 4: Well, it was a bunch of divine
appointments for me. I had a dream in the spring
of 2015 that I'd be meeting Donald Trump. And I'm
going, why would I want to meet Donald Trump?
And all of a sudden he comes down the escalator
running for president. Then I had it in my book.
I explain all this I I actually to the National
Prayer Breakfast in early two thousand sixteen.
And when Ben Carson was still running for office
and I was picked out of twelve people out of
the whole prayer breakfast with thousands there
to pray on to with Ben Carson in a room. And
just these things kept happening to me and
it was building up and I'm going this all has to
mean something. And it went mean that I just end
up going golfing with Donald Trump or something.
And I think there was so many divine appointments
that led up to that. And then I just it was
something different, something that, you know,
because I had met him. I just know this had all
these things that happened. I look at that to know
that God exists. I use mathematics and say, if you
have a one in a million happen or one in a billion
or this thing or this thing happens, that could
never happen when you add them together and
consider a miracle. And that's what kept happening
to me. And I'm going, I got this. He's been
picked. Who's been chosen for such a time as wow.
Speaker 1: So if I hear you correctly,
you're saying what others might see as odds
and probability you see as divine appointment.
Speaker 4: Absolutely. Wow. Look at and especially
when there's more than one and then there's
confirmations of that. Wow. You know, here's a
guy for me being just an ecstatic from Minnesota,
a guy very functioning addict girl, you know,
growing up. And and here I end up and I end up
in the White House, I'll tell you an example. So
I end up in the White House at a roundtable event.
I never thought I could come within a hundred
yards of the White House with my pals.
Speaker 1: I see. I see. I see
Speaker 4: and hear. I hear. I end up in
the White House. I said, who's sitting here? And
they go, the president. There's like fifteen of
us in the room. First time I was over the White
House. And they do that. We go on national TV,
then it's just him and I facing forward
and it went viral that that screen shot and
all my friends are going, what is this extract
sitting next to the president? United States?
Jesus is real because this could not happen.
Speaker 1: This makes no sense. Right.
In other words, it's almost like Mike Lyndell
pillow guy being at the White House makes such
little sense. It must be divine intervention.
Speaker 4: Absolutely. Absolutely. Wow. That's
just like when I spoke at the Rose Garden
there, when we when I went there and we did
start making mass, we had got a I got a letter
from the White House saying, would you come in
and not because we had started making Mazzarino
one of the first ones, I believe, in the country.
And we get there and he's going to have us all
speak from the Rose Garden. And you have to have
pre pre-approved remarks. And if I told you the
whole story, I mean, it's just it's divine how
everything went down. That's I'm sitting in the
front row, right. There's things that couldn't
happen. And that was a series of events happened
there where I ended up being the only one on
stage with them and then asked him if I could say
something off the cuff and flip this paper over
and then spoke out about I remember getting back
in the word and and it if you know you to think
there, I mean, that was that was heard around
the world. I did one hundred nine interviews
in seven and five days.
Speaker 1: Well, Mike, listen,
there's so many things I want to ask you about,
let me do a few that are sort of like shorter
things. One is in terms of states that were
given to Joe Biden that you believe Donald Trump
won. What is the how extensive is that list?
Speaker 4: It's huge and and it's absolutely
huge. And not that I believe I know he won
because we have all the packaged captures
and the data from the whole election. We'll get
to that in Minnesota, New Hampshire, all the
swing states we talk about, Nevada, Georgia,
Michigan, Wisconsin, Arizona, Pennsylvania.
Wow. I mean, the list goes on and on. It's there
are very few that Biden more or less than 10.
Speaker 1: You at one point I heard
you say you believe Trump even won
California. Do you still believe that?
Speaker 4: That that's that's correct.
And we're going to reveal that at the Cyber
Symposium. I happy these are going to be
we actually will have the data to back that up.
Speaker 1: What's the math? Just to pick one,
Mike, for people to understand, California
has twenty two million registered voters.
Ten million are Democrats and there's five
million Republicans. How did Trump win California?
Speaker 4: I didn't see one for sure. We're going
to reveal at the symposium. Let's use Minnesota,
OK? My home state, they are losing Minnesota by a
hundred thousand votes. No, I went around all over
and I would say, oh, Minneapolis. And we only have
like two big cities, Duluth and Minneapolis, St.
Paul. And it's all Democrats supposedly right. In
all our northern Minnesota Democrat. Well, that's
that's the past. Everybody that Democrat, that
ship sailed. Those were traditional Democrats,
a lot of them. Well, in Minnesota, the actual
number, Minnesota one, Donald Trump won by sixty
five thousand. And we will show this to at the
symposium. Yeah, this is Alex. These are facts.
And how did that happen? Because it doesn't
matter where the the past everything changed
with Donald Trump. People people are voting,
I believe people are voting for they want
politicians that are for the people that you know.
And Donald Trump did stuff for all people. If you
get to our great this great place where we're in
in December of twenty nineteen, I think everyone,
whether you're a Democrat or Republican,
realizes that those those that the month
that was a manifestation of a of a couple of
years of decisions being made by politicians,
i.e. Donald Trump and by me and those common
sense decisions that made here's a problem,
here's a solution. How would help people, all
people, not just their party or a personal agenda?
And that's what and we've seen that that was it
was just awesome that everyone in this country
got to experience that what what political
decisions would could could manifest to.
And everything was great thing. We had
consumer confidence, lowest gas prices,
lowest unemployment, unemployment. I mean, the
list goes on and on. Yeah. I mean, across the
board. Those were because of political decisions.
Speaker 1: Everybody, I want to focus in on the
election piece just so we kind of
keep the keep that path forward.
There are some like Marjorie Taylor Green,
who, while she believes there were problems
with the election, she says Trump is not coming
back. He it is false hope to believe he will be
reinstated. You've said August or September. Do
you still believe that? And what's the mechanism?
Speaker 4: One hundred percent. I believe
that she's just she's misconstrued. I mean,
all these this is here's there's a couple of
things here. We're having this cyber symposium
after that. That's August 10th, 11th and 12th.
Everybody's going to watch this. I want it to be
the biggest watched event in history. Yeah,
brilliant people. You watch that and you're
going to see the packet captures and data from the
whole election. This is non subjective evidence,
everybody. It's what I've had for months now
and I've been trying to get the word out,
but I keep let's just cancel Mike Lyndell and
my pillow. I've been trying to get the word
out. Now this gets out. We've had it ready
for the Supreme Court. It's called a, quote,
warrant. So we bring that to the Supreme Court and
everyone says, well, they're not going to bring
back Donald Trump. Yes, they are. Here's why.
Speaker 1: So hold on, Mike. I want to I want
to hear it, but I want to make sure the
audience doesn't miss it. The Supreme Court
is the mechanism that will bring them back.
Speaker 4: You're saying there's there's more
than one, but I'm giving you the first one. OK,
OK, the easiest one. OK, OK, the easiest one.
This when we get through the cyber symposium,
which everybody needs to tell everybody to watch,
this is so important because these nine Supreme
Court justices, they're people, too. They've
lived the American dream. They have families,
they have children, grandchildren, friends,
family. They need everyone. Everyone needs to
watch this because it shows that this was an
attack by China on our country. It doesn't
matter if you're a Democrat or Republican.
I said on Jimmy Kimmel, I said Jimmy said if it
was reversed, Mike, would you do the same thing?
Absolutely I would. This is an attack on a
country. So what happens is in our country's
history, every elected official, everyone that you
find out later, there was a crime committed, i.e.
election fraud. The real winner gets put back
in. It's happened every single election. Now,
that's never happened at the presidential
level. Right. The only difference. So there is
precedence. But also you combine this with this
is an attack by China. This was a very, very,
very it's it's an act of war basically is why
they've attacked us. And the Democrats warned us
of this. Everybody they warned us from my senator,
Amy Klobuchar to Kamala Harris. They all warned
us about this cyber attack, about going through
the machines and taking our country without guns.
And they just happened to use the Democrat Party.
So no matter who you are, we go back to now.
The Supreme Court's going to get this. Yeah,
we're going to give up probably late August.
And now what they do with it, I'm not the Supreme
Court, but they'll have some options. They might,
you know, pull it down and put Donald Trump in
right away because the evidence is non subjective.
I see. Or or because all the down tickets were
affected. Too many, many down tickets. Maybe
the Supreme Court I'm just putting it out there,
has a whole new election. Wow. Well, how could
we have a new election, right, with these with
these machines? We can't. But at the symposium on
the 10th, 11th and 12th of August, members live
streamed on free speech worldwide, of course,
and worldwide free speech dotcom. We're going
to live stream of seventy, 72 hours straight.
We're going to unveil a replacement for the
machines. And everyone says, well, Mike, are you
going to do that now? You're going to show this
is just a money thing so you can make money. No,
we're giving the technology away to all companies.
Speaker 1: OK, OK. But so to me, I want to go one
thing because there's so much here. My head is
literally spinning here, Mike, just to show how
confident you are that this reinstatement would
happen. Would you want to make a financial bet
with me on it? Because I just don't see it. And
I want to prove to people just how confident
you are. Would you want to put twenty five
thousand dollars up against me on it that by
the end of September, Trump is reinstatement
Speaker 4: of my addiction's was gambling.
But but I will tell you this. I put up five
million dollars a prize. Yeah. Cyber symposium,
five million dollars for anyone that's there,
which is we've invited them. We have over
one hundred cyber cyber forensic experts
from around the country and a couple from
out of out of this country. What what
Speaker 1: is that? What does that
mean? A cyber friend? What's that
credential? A cyber forensic astro.
Speaker 4: They have CISSP, but
it's more than that. These are
these are guys that protect our country.
A lot of them work for the government
when you have a cyber attack. These are
experts that can read these packet captures
that can just, you know, what actually happened.
The you know, it shows where the attack came from,
the computer that was intruded, how many votes
were flipped. They're going to read all this
during the 72 hours. We're going to go through all
50 states and a packet capture. Everybody is like
a picture. You can't change. You can't all.
Speaker 1: That's true. But Mike and this is
so important because I've looked I saw the
packet captures and I saw the numbers and
I went in preparation for the interview to be
thorough. I went to some cyber experts on this.
What they told me is that what you previewed
I don't remember if it was unfranked speech
or on Newsmax or where it was a couple of weeks
ago. But you you showed the numbers scrolling.
They said that that's absolutely meaningless,
that those are called hex dumps and it's
just the way to look at computer memories.
Speaker 4: Just write we just put Berel out there.
Those aren't the capturers. So we put Beeber. All
those are from the election. Those every single
every single outlet, including CNN. I just
did a two and a half hour interview with them
about four days ago. OK, let's show you what
this data, if you're any kind of a cyber guy,
you can decipher and say, well, that
was from the twenty twenty election.
OK, I should have told you that.
Speaker 1: So what you're saying is
what you put up there is the style of what
you will be unveiling at the symposium,
but it is not the actual data.
Speaker 4: Those were actual data.
Speaker 1: It was actual data
Speaker 4: that actual data,
one hundred percent actual data. So if you
talk to guys, that was it. No, that wasn't
PAC and captured. That was data from the PAC it
captures that were captured. So what we're going
to do at the Cyber Symposium, you're going to be
able to go up to imagine this. We're going to have
on stage we're going to have a panel and we're
going to go just like election night in the state
of New Hampshire goes to Donald Trump. Whoa,
this will be the real election. OK, well, on the
to the side of the stage, we have a cyber cyber
center. Any of these politicians or the media,
if you got you invited yourself, David, if you
want to come in, then then you can get your five
million dollar prize. You can bring your own cyber
guys. Absolutely. If you're beside the stage,
you'll be able to punch in a state or. The county
or the whole election, if you punched in the whole
election, you got Donald Trump winning 80 million
to 68 million, but now you do this. Now, listen,
we're going to help these cyber guys that came
from all over the country. These are none of
them know each other. They were just they were
you know, we invited and they called in. They
provided them that they're the they're good.
They're the best. OK, they're going to divide up
into groups like, let's say, eight to a group and
we're going to give them a state. Here's the state
of Georgia. Here's the raw data. And they're
going to sit there and make sure 100 percent
that what I'm telling you is the truth. They'll
go through it and they're going to go through it.
I say I say they're going to and then we're
going to have them on the stage and they're
going to have the people. It's like reading
a language. Let's say let's say this was all
written in Chinese. You'd have to have people
there that could read the Chinese and say,
yup, this is what it says. Now, since it's non
subjective, every cyber guy will say the exact
same thing. And when you're watching that from
home now, when you're watching that anybody, cyber
guy or anybody in the world that sees this will
be one hundred percent, not ninety two percent
by the time this symposium is over, everyone,
Democrats, Republicans, liberals, conservatives
are going to go, wow, we need to do something. No,
this was an attack by China. This is real. These
heroes that captured this information, which is
these captures our government should be doing this
because the Democrats weren't it. But yeah, but
you don't. They said, oh, they're none of the
machines were online. So why would you it'd be
like getting flood insurance when you say, hey,
there's not going to be any water what they
like. Yeah, they like the American people.
Speaker 1: So I'm out of breath from all of
this information that you're giving me. Mike,
there's a couple other things I want to get
to. And maybe on the I know your time is short,
so maybe we can keep these short. I am not
a Christian, so I may not be in a position
to understand this. But if Donald Trump was
selected by God, as you are certain that he was,
why would God allow Joe Biden to even become
president and force you to go through all of this?
Why not just put Trump in the White House again?
Speaker 4: Well, I believe I believe that that's
that's part of this divine, divine thing that's
going on because really people don't look, let
me tell you, people do not look for hope unless
things are going bad. And this and that's why
I believe this will be the greatest revival for
Jesus. And we will be once again one nation under
God ever, because all these people, including
yourself, are going to see miracles unfold here.
Speaker 1: Mike, are you saying even even
even a Jewish guy like me will see Jesus?
OK, what's that? Even a Jewish guy like me,
Speaker 4: you're going to see miracles.
You're going to OK, miracles unfold. You're
going to see miracles unfold. You can believe
whatever you want, but you're going to see
things that you thought were impossible. OK,
happen. And you're sad. You asked me why would
God why would God let this happen? Yeah, well,
if you don't, people don't. Look, I'll give you an
example. I was you know, I was in about two years
ago, I met the guy and he said and he goes, Mike,
our nation has turned his back on God. People
have turned his back on him. And he says we would
need people aren't looking for God unless things
bad happen. And he said he goes, if something like
the Great Depression, I said, no, no. In the Great
Depression, they had God. They were just praying
for food and shelter. I said, we have something
better than that. I said, we have addiction. I
said, So this is when I set up my Lindow Recovery
Network tonner. I said, When you're in addiction,
you're looking for hope. You're looking out there,
you need and it's about your soul, about
salvation. You're praying, OK, but then along came
the China virus, the pandemic. And then came this
election. Everybody everybody is seeing what is
going on. No, I have Democrat friends of mine and
liberal friends of mine. I talk to them. They go,
wow, wow. Believe this. Mike, you were right.
This is a manifestation. And I'm not blaming
the Democrat Party. I'm saying that the China
picked them and they use them. And you're going
to see this at the symposium. I see. So you're
going to see these when people see what's coming,
straightening out our country. I'll give you an
example to David. Jim, when Jimmy Kimmel said to
me in his attack, he said, Mike, would you do it
if it was reversed? I said, of course, this isn't
about Donald Trump. I said, this is about saving
our country with with China and these machines.
This is about saving not just our country, but the
world. All these other countries are worried, too.
They got we are in an age where cyber attacks.
Yeah. Computers that can take your country. And
I and you know what happened after that? They
came back, The Washington Post and all these
outlets came to Minnesota and asked my friends
and people from my past, come on with Mike,
really be sounding the alarm. If Donald Trump if
they depict him trying to pick every one of them
said yes. David, do you think they did a story on
that? No, every one. Because you know what? This
is about our country. This is about election.
I don't it doesn't matter who won or lost it.
It's when your vote didn't matter. And you're
going to see that at the cyber symposium.
Nobody's vote mattered during that. Nobody.
Sport matter, they use the 2010 census report,
that's why you have so many rural counties where
double the people voted didn't even live in the
county and this was all these are done on
a total separate figure with mathematics.
Yeah, that we could better prove this.
Speaker 1: Mike, there's this incredible
image of you in the aftermath of the
election, leaving the White House and
a zoomed in picture sees you carrying a paper
that says martial law on it. We raised the topic
of martial law in that meeting with Trump.
Speaker 4: Well, see, now, if you had done
your due diligence on that, David, I said I was
bringing him the evidence I got on January 9th,
the cyber evidence that I got brought to me on
January 9th. OK, that was four pages. These other
lawyers had given me two pages to give to him. I
had never even read it. I didn't know what was on
it that got opened up. It never got talked about
in the Oval Office. That's a very famous story. I
brought in the evidence. This is why
Speaker 1: I'm asking you.
Speaker 4: Yeah, yeah. But he said, bring this
upstairs. The lawyers brought me upstairs. Now
the sheets robe, they gave me the sheets
back and I was outside the back yard.
And then they see that martial law in there. It
was never brought up in the Oval Office. It was
OK. And he didn't even the sheets were given
back. And I brought upstairs to his attorneys,
which showed me out of the White
Speaker 1: House, OK, that's why I'm asking
to get the story straight from you to other real
Speaker 4: you know what we. Yes, but that was so
important. You know why? Yeah, because no no media
would talk to Mike Lyndell. So from that point on
every single day I was attacked by bots and
trolls, by retailers are gone on my shopping
channels. They attacked Mike Lindale, my pillow
dominion shoot over two hundred people and use
law fear in our country to wear. This week I just
had to dump Fox. Shame on Fox News. I had to use
all the left wing media every day. They have my
direct number. I get calls from morning to night,
but what about me? And they attacked me.
But at least I get to talk about the truth,
which is trying to protect our country well and
stole our election from the American people.
Speaker 1: Last two things. One, do you have
voting machines in your possession somewhere?
Speaker 4: Yes, we do,
Speaker 1: you do, and how many of them
Speaker 4: I don't know that I don't know
that I have no idea where we're going to have
that's knowing we're going to have a the
cyber symposium. We're going to show you
mock elections. We're going to have random
cyber people put in a soundproof room.
We're going to capture the packets which
are in the routers. Of course, that's why
you're in. And Sony won't give up the routers.
Speaker 1: Strong routers. Yeah. Where did you
get the voting machines? Where did you get them?
Speaker 4: No lawyer's gonna believe me
they were Gotlieb, you can buy them on
eBay. OK, but why don't you buy a couple?
Speaker 1: I don't have any use for them,
quite frankly. Last thing, my frank speech, it
was billed as it will be the new revolutionary
social website. When I check it, it's just like a
video of you talking. What's going on with that?
Speaker 4: That's Lyndell TV. That's correct.
You're very incorrect. If you go there, there's
thousands of these are all of the network part
was built first. So all these people that have
had their voices suppressed. Yeah. Like your
like your, I don't know, pick anyone that has
been kicked off a YouTube or Vimeo for talking
about machines or vaccines or even or even Jesus,
they kicked off their canceled out. Now they're
over here. So we have a safe place where they know
they don't have their platform pulled. That's our
network part. The social media part is coming out
probably in a month or two. It's OK. And that
that's the part where people can go like the
Twitter right now for me, the the media
part of it. So we would have a voice. We
have millions of people on there now. And so
when I talk, the word's getting out instead
of people like Fox that don't let the word out.
Right. So now at least I have the terrible media
that bashes me every day and I'm able to talk him
on my own platform and put out stuff that doesn't
get censored. It's our First Amendment right to
free speech, like Alan Dershowitz said. Well, he's
one of my attorneys. He said, really don't like
this will be the most important case for our First
Amendment right of free speech in history because
they only use law for one other time in 1798.
Why were these Lopper just suppressed? So if
you get you know, it'll be amazing appearing
on your show, if you could say Dominion,
Dominion, Dominion or Smartmatic. Smartmatic.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, Mike, I appreciate your
time so much. Ah, if if this doesn't work out, are
you open to the idea that maybe Joe Biden just won
or are you even even theoretically open to that?
Speaker 4: I put everything I had. You're going
to watch it, too. So I would really like it if
you came and brought a cyber guy, tried to
win the five million dollar prize. Well, I
know in the beginning here, you kind of mocked
it. I'll bet you. Twenty five thousand. I know
you don't believe it. You don't know people.
Speaker 1: That was serious. I bet you.
Speaker 4: Twenty five an invite to
the symposium and you can send your own
your own cyber guy win the five million
dollar prize. You could expand your audience.
Speaker 1: I'm traveling on that day.
Speaker 4: There is one hundred percent. No
chance that this didn't happen because I'm
showing evidence. You need to understand
how it captures. I have it for the whole election.
I have it in my possession. It's like. I mean,
it's like. It's just a phone. Yes, it's a phone.
That's why it's going to be a nine zero vote from
the Supreme Court. Wow. Because you're not even
asking him about anything that's subjective.
This is the evidence. It's like it's like you and
I taking a picture in the 1970s where you couldn't
alter it. Right. You know, you can't alter
it. You can't change it. It shows everything
in detail about the it captures it's
like why in Arizona did they want to
give up the rooters? Because those show the PECC
captures. If you ask any cyber guy in the world
if you have a cyber attack, which we have all
the time on private businesses. Yep, government,
everything. We just had a gasline one. These cyber
experts that I hired to validate this evidence,
remember, I spent about twelve million.
Fifty million dollars. No. On my own money
to validate all this evidence so that I could sit
here and tell you I've already had the people the
best in the world look at it. And they said,
these are people that protect our country and
this is one hundred percent. I said, it's
not ninety nine point nine. They said No.
One hundred percent. I said, well, when you when
you have a cyber attack or breach is what's that
you don't do you need more. They said no. If you
have the pack of captors you have it all blow.
Speaker 1: Mike Lyndell, CEO and inventor
of my pillow. Mike, you've really said it
all. I we will be watching. We will be
waiting for what will happen over the
next month or two. I really appreciate your
time and telling us your perspective today.
Speaker 4: Know if everybody can get to I want the
everyone needs to watch this show you if you watch
free speech dotcom and you watch it any time
during those 72 hours, that's all you're going
to need and you're going to be worried about.
I am about our country are going to go. David,
you'll be the first one to call me. I'll give you
my direct number. Well, what are we going to do?
Speaker 1: I will be watching. Mike,
appreciate it. Thank you. Thanks, David.